the elephant calf 9 was born in the
elephant conservation centre home to the
only elephant breeding center in Laos
these elephants don't carry tourists
about they can wander around freely the
Wildlife conservationists with the NGO
elephant Asia are dedicated to the
protection of the endangered elephant
lung sanjuana is a mahute an elephant
caretaker he explains that about half of
the 1011 slept and Laos are used for
labour elephants can't always find
enough to eat
they're often malnourished and weak so
if they're forced to work they often end
up dying that's what happened a lot of
villages and in many places wild
elephants have died out - such as the
village of nong bua this is one of the
poorest regions in the country all
that's left of the jungle that used to
be here are these roots most of the
forests were destroyed in the 1990s the
village elder can remember a time when a
herd of wild elephants destroyed the
rice paddies but illegal logging has
changed everything we used to rely on
the jungle we'd find useful plants their
healing herbs and mushrooms
we need our jungle back much of the
former jungle has since been replaced by
bamboo it's one of the world's fastest
growing plants and it's useful as a raw
material for the villagers but they
still have a lot to learn about
sustainable bamboo forestry but Sami
Bopha from the Faculty of forest science
at the National University of Laos
teaches locals how to use bamboos
sustainably the German government
supports the project then booths have
several important purposes
it helps find carbon dioxide in the
earth prevents erosion stores moisture
and functions like a natural fertilizer
it has significant economic potential
for locals villagers use bamboo for
household purposes to build their homes
and to make furniture around two thirds
of the song Tong region is now covered
with bamboo forests sections of the
bamboo forest are reserved for other
rare trees such as rosewood
the ultimate goal is the emergence of
mixed woodland that can provide a home
for greater biodiversity meanwhile the
elephant conservation center is
pampering the elephant may come D she
will give birth soon for Wildlife
conservationists in Laos where only four
elephants are born every year it's a ray
of hope